hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar vertical rotors and how to
achieve higher Purity and yield viral
vectors with greater efficiency I am
Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Beckman Coulter life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Sean
sternership PhD senior field application
scientists at Beckman quilter Sean you
may now begin your presentation
uh thank you for the introduction and
thanks everyone for joining I'm really
happy to present this educational
webinar to you where I will discuss
vertical rotors and some of the
advantages that they have
so this slide is just uh some legal
notices including Regulatory and
trademark statements that were required
to share as well as intellectual
property statements
and here's a general agenda for our talk
today so I'll start by going over the
different types of density gradients and
and why density gradients are used
and then from there I'll discuss some of
the current state and what most of our
our customers are doing nowadays as well
as a look towards future State and how
you might be able to optimize your
workflow
and then from there I'll transition into
some case studies uh showing vertical
rotors and some of the benefits they
have in very specific cases
as well as some of the key conclusions
and additional opportunities to optimize
your workflow
so with that I can I can jump into it
um this slide here is meant to be pretty
high level it's it's really showing what
density gradients are used for and you
can tell that it's a a pretty broad
range here
uh at the highest of levels density
gradients are chosen for difficult
separations that require very high
Purity and high yield
there's a lot of applications within
life science research where density
gradients are used there on the left you
can see viruses and so here I'm thinking
kind of viral vectors and things like
that where
there's often a inefficiency in terms of
packaging of that nucleic acid cargo
within the the capsid itself and so you
end up with a diverse population ranging
from empty partial and full capsids this
is one of the biggest use cases of uh
density gradients nowadays and in that
that actual image there you can see a
discrete separation between uh each of
those species
uh they're in in the light blue too you
can see extracellular vesicles this is
another really great example of
um the power of density gradients really
a lot of people tend to purify these
using pelleting that can be a great
method as well it really depends on what
your output is but what density
gradients allow you to do is to separate
these on on the basis of their their
density which I'll I'll talk quite a bit
more about but you can really start to
fractionate out some of these distinct
sub populations of extracellular
vesicles
uh and then finally in the light green
you can see some proteins there this is
another really common use case for
density gradients where you've got a
protein complex that you're trying to
separate out uh from from other
contaminating proteins
uh and and I'll talk about rate zonal
separations which is primarily what
that's using but you can really get a
nice fractionation of these using
density gradients so really when you're
looking for Purity and yield and the
separation is relatively difficult in
terms of you know the the sample of
Interest being different from what
you're trying to to remove
uh density gradients are a really great
option here
okay so uh density gradients uh come in
a lot of different variations uh the
first one I'll talk about here is isopic
and so these are density gradients where
you're trying to
um separate out materials on the basis
of their buoyant density
and so typically you'll use a
self-forming gradient in this case but
really what you're looking for in ISO
picnic gradient is a linear or
continuous gradient at the end
um cesium chloride is probably the best
example of this
and these gradients are really used when
you're looking for the highest possible
purity
um really when you have that continued
continuous or linear gradient you're
going to get the best uh differentiation
between different densities and then
that that plot
graphic that you can see there at the
bottom illustrates kind of a typical
approach for this where in the before
picture you you start with generally a
uniform concentration of your sample as
well as your density forming material
and then after you throw it in the
centrifuge you end up with that that
linear gradient that I've been
mentioning as well as a distinct
separation between your bands of
Interest
similar to that is equilibrium zonal uh
it's a very similar technique to isopic
except in this case what you're doing is
is often starting with a uh
pre-formed type of gradient so it's not
necessarily continuous but you've got to
find steps along the way
the output of this or the goal of this
rather is to separate again on the basis
of buoyant density
however in this case because you're not
actually forming a linear gradient the
resolution is often a little bit a
little bit lower than what you'd see
with ISO picnic
uh on on the the flip side to that
though you can often achieve these
separations quite a bit quicker uh and
so the the illustration there at the
bottom again is showing you that instead
of starting with a uniform concentration
of gradient uh material as well as
sample
now you've got distinct layers of your
density forming material and your sample
there on top
you get similar separation but the
resolution tends to be a bit lower as I
mentioned you can achieve this quicker
uh so for something like aav or a
demo-associated virus this tends to be a
pretty popular option because it's a
good balance between resolution and uh
throughput or time
and the last example I'll share here is
uh rate zonal and this one tends to be
the most different compared to the other
two uh this is when you want to separate
materials on the basis of size and mass
uh in other words on sedimentation
coefficient
and in these experiments again you're
using more of a preformed gradient
it's similar to ISO picnic in the sense
that you're using a continuous or linear
gradient for it
but the actual process itself once it's
in the centrifuge is quite different so
here instead of waiting to reach
equilibrium and and seeing those
particles migrate to where their buoyant
density is equal to that of the
surrounding media
you're actually kind of starting with
more of a race here so all of your
particles start at the top of a tube and
from there they'll start to migrate or
pellet down towards the bottom
and that's directly related to their
sedimentation coefficient and so things
that are bigger and heavier and more
dense will start to sediment more
quickly and so you can achieve a pretty
good separation between things
using this technique and it's more of a
race rather than an equilibrium type
experiment
um typical gradient materials used for
this are sucrose and iodixinol
uh and and again it's used for
um separating particles that are
different sizes rather than different
densities all of these are quite common
it really just depends on what the use
case is
so this is a relatively generic workflow
for the production of Advanced
Therapeutics so again things like viral
vectors like aav
um usually you start with an upstream
part of the workflow where you've got
cell expansion as well as
transfection and then finally production
of your virus itself
and then in the downstream stage of the
workflow
um that's when you start to get more
into the purification right and we'll
talk a lot more about that and then
finally as as the end point basically
it's a vile fill and finish to make sure
you've got a adequate finalized product
but in terms of purification we're
focusing on dguc or density gradient
Ultra centrifugation and so I'll talk
through some of the steps of that method
here
the first thing you want to do is choose
a gradient material uh I've already
mentioned a few of those cesium chloride
sucrose iodixinol
those tend to be the most common options
uh generally they've got pretty
well-defined use cases in terms of when
you'd want to use one over the other
another thing you'd want to do is is
choose a gradient method and those are
all the things I've talked about on the
previous slide in terms of what's going
to give you the best separation for your
sample type
after you've decided those things you'll
want to load and run the rotor and so
the first first part of this is
um choosing the type of tube so there's
a variety of tubes that we offer here at
Beckman in terms of tube sealing we've
got permanent seal tube so things like a
heat seal
uh for the best bio containment we've
also got plug ceiling tubes and then
finally open top tubes and I'll talk
more about those uh towards the end of
the talk as well
choosing a tube material can be
important obviously you want to ensure
um compatibility with your sample type
and then finally choosing a rotor and
this is really going to be the focus of
the talk today how do you choose the
right rotor which rotor is best for your
application that's what I'll spend the
most time focusing on for this
finally sample recovery there's two
really common methods that are used here
um
simple extraction of a band is generally
done by piercing the side of a tube
using a syringe and a needle and that's
where you're able to visualize your band
you see exactly what it is that you want
to pull out and and you do that through
the side of the tube the other option is
fractionation
Um this can be done in a lot of
different instances but typically you
pierce the bottom of the tube and in a
manual sense you you would fractionate
that and drip it into the bottom of a
well plate
but we've got a lot of customers
nowadays too that are using actas so
chromatography systems to fractionate
their sample here and do direct inline
measurements of what's inside so really
some some strong options there just
depends on what you're trying to do
so this slide is uh meant to show the
different types of rotors that are
offered and when you might want to use
each one over some of the others so what
you see there on the left is the
um The Swinging bucket rotors
I mentioned this a bit already but these
are used for rate zonal type experiments
where it really is a race from start to
finish so the long path length of these
tubes is really advantageous in those
you can also use these for pelleting or
floatation
in those cases typically you'd use this
kind of rotor because the um
sample of interest that you're trying to
pellet ends up being a pretty small mass
and so one of the good examples of this
is extracellular vesicles or exosomes
where you don't end with a lot of them
and so being able to visualize is really
important for this
as well as pellet stability to making
sure they stick to the bottom of the
tube but not stick stick hard enough to
result in damage
so these rotors are really great for
that the angle of these rotors is 90
degrees for those of you not familiar
with swing bucket rotors as you can see
in that example really your your buckets
hang down to the bottom of the tube but
once it starts spinning the centrifugal
force pulls those up towards a 90 degree
angle and they're actually flying out
there on the side and so the path length
again is quite long when you're at speed
for fixed angle rotors on the other hand
um these have a pretty different use
case uh they're generally used for
pelleting or floatation but I would say
more so pelleting
the angle in this case tends to be 20 to
30 degrees and they're really great for
large scale type experiments where
you're pelleting a bunch of stuff and
you don't have to worry about visibility
of that pellet so something like
propelling lentivirus or a protein
that's been precipitated out using Peg
our best-selling rotor for that is the
type 70 TI it's got a really high speed
but also a pretty good volume
and the path length for this at speed is
is quite Medium as you can see there in
the uh graphic at the bottom
uh the next one is near vertical they're
in the purple and this is where you
start to get more into the ice of picnic
or equilibrium zonal space and that's
probably what we'll focus on most today
um the angle for these rotors is usually
between 7 and 10 degrees so pretty close
to vertical and these are really great
for density gradients similar to
Vertical rotors but the use case for
these is when you tend to have samples
which have larger amounts of
contaminants so if you if you expect
something to either pellet or float it
can be really advantageous to use this
near vertical rotor that way you don't
get accumulation of that contaminant on
the side of the tube and the nvt65 is
the rotor I'm illustrating there
and then all the way at the bottom the
the path length for these is quite short
um it's it's near vertical
and then finally what we'll focus on
today is the vertical rotors again
really great for the iso picnic and
equilibrium zonal experiments the
there's no angle here these rotor these
tubes rather in the rotor are perfectly
vertical and these are uh simply put the
best options for density gradient type
purifications where you're using isopic
or equilibrium zonal so the only
difference there would be rate zone if
you're doing that you might want to use
something else
but these are fantastic when the density
between what you're trying to separate
is is uh pretty small
the vti 50.1 rotor is the example there
and I'll talk a lot more about that and
in terms of path length very short um
You can compare the illustrations or the
graphics at the bottom of the screen
there for each of these rotors
this one very clearly has the shortest
path link
so I'll jump now into kind of current
state and what most of our customers are
doing uh using these these different
rotors
and so the first thing that I want to
talk about is fixed angled and Swinging
bucket rotors uh these are currently the
most common rotors that we have uh for
empty and full separation so that's
empty and full virus particles typically
things like aav or adenovirus
and the the really the question is why
are they used so much if I've been
telling you this whole time that
vertical Road of the best why are
swinging bucket and fixed angles so
popular
and I'll I'll go through some examples
of this so the first reason for this is
for the established literature base
uh so I'm showing a graph there on the
right side and you can see in green is
the sw32 it's our best-selling swinging
bucket rotor and then in in blue or cyan
is our type 70 and then finally in red
is our vti 50.
um we've actually come out with a better
version of this rotor since so we no
longer sell this but we chose it for
this illustration because this is kind
of where the established literature is
at
uh you can see a pretty Stark difference
here right
um the reason for that I I think is
probably because of a feedback loop most
people don't know where to start with
this
and so what they end up doing is taking
a look at the literature and seeing that
a lot of a lot of people are using type
70 TI or type uh or sw32ti and so they
end up just doing the same thing because
they can follow those protocols
but there's other reasons for this as
well versatility certainly is one uh
especially as it pertains to fixed
angled rotors these are useful for all
centrifuge based separations so
everything I've shared with you so far
in terms of different types of methods
pelleting isopic equilibrium zonal rate
zonal really the fixed angle can do all
of them is it the best at all of them no
but it can do all of them and so if
you're on a budget constraint or
something like that it might be the best
option for you and again they're they're
used in a a broad range of applications
as well so extracellular vesicles
um viral vectors cells everything so
there really is a strong
um rationale for choosing a fixed angle
rotor if that's what you're trying to do
and then finally I think is the
knowledge Gap and so that's what I'm
hoping to address a bit here today in
terms of
why vertical rotors are so good for
these specific types of separations
they're not really good for anything
else but when it comes to isopic or
equilibrium zonal separations vertical
rotors are by far the most efficient and
so that's what I'll be trying to
um
uh share with you today
so that's current state a lot of people
are using swinging bucket and fixed
angle when they really should be using
the vertical rotors uh and to go into
more detail about that
um
I'll start here and so this slide is
meant to illustrate how you might
separate some similarly dense particles
right so at the top there I've Got The
Swinging bucket section and then at the
bottom is the vertical rotor section uh
so right now we're looking at the tubes
at rest before you start spinning them
at all so before they're even put into
the centrifuge
what most of our customers do is they
start with a homogeneous distribution of
cesium chloride or whatever their
density gradient forming material is
cesium chloride just tends to be the
most popular for viral vectors
uh and so
often they'll add a solid amount of
cesium chloride to this tube to a
defined final density
so really what I'm trying to show on the
screen there is that these two different
types of rotors start in the exact same
point
um you've got this uniform distribution
of density gradient material as well as
your sample of Interest
where things start to differ however is
once it starts spinning
and so starting at the top there with
swinging bucket when it starts spinning
as I mentioned these tubes will fly out
to the side at a 90 degree angle and
start spinning that way and so your
G-Force is is towards the right there as
the arrow indicates
these cesium chloride particles or
whatever your density forming material
is have a very long distance to travel
because that path length is so long
so you end up with a gradient that forms
quite slowly
in contrast to that the vertical rotor
has a pretty short path length and
there's really not a very large distance
for these particles to travel and so
that ends up resulting in a much much
faster gradient formation
so if we compare what happens at the end
right once your centrifuge has come back
down to to zero RPM so at rest after
spinning uh and I will mention here too
that
we have a lot of uh customers that we've
spoken with with in the past that
um don't apply any break to these
experiments and I can say we've not
actually seen a difference between
applying maximum break and zero break uh
at least not a quantifiable difference
so that's a good way for you to save
time if you're already implementing
density gradients in your workflow just
apply maximum break and I'll actually
show example of that later
but the the takeaway from this really is
once the centrifugees stops spinning at
rest these two tubes are equal it's just
that the vertical rotor got there much
quicker because of that short path line
uh that's not the only advantage that
vertical rotors have however
um they can also improve your resolution
and so that's what I'm going to share on
this slide
um again the same type of layout here
we've got swing bucket at the top and
and vertical there at the bottom
except now we're not starting with
pre-centrifugation we're starting with
while the tube is actually spinning and
so you can actually see the the
difference there between the orientation
of the tubes but while The Swinging
bucket tube is spinning
um and the gradient's been formed the
density range is is quite Broad and the
main reason for this is because there's
a significant change in uh relative
centrifugal force between the minimum
radius and the maximum radius of this
tube
and so just uh some hypothetical numbers
there could be 1.05 grams per ML on the
minimum radius and 1.45 on the max
radius
and if we jump down to the bottom with
the vertical rotor again this is while
spinning after the gradient has been
formed uh the density range here so the
range from lower value to to the highest
value is is uh really low so this is a
very shallow gradient that's being
formed here there's very little change
in density from one end of the tube to
the other uh and the example here is 1.3
to 1.4 grams per ml
that might not sound like much right now
but once the tube actually stops
spinning it results in a pretty
significant difference and so jumping
back up to the top there with the swing
bucket rotor
um there's going to be reorientation of
this entire tube uh as the the rotor
comes to a stop
and that gradient is unchanged upon
reorientation so the difference in those
bands in terms of their their physical
difference between each other is not
going to change
and at the bottom you can see what the
vertical rotor looks like so in this
case the tubes themselves are not
changing they're spinning at zero
degrees right but you end up getting a
reorientation of the gradient itself and
the tube shape um that we have here
really facilitates a smooth orientation
of that and you actually end up getting
an expansion of those bands upon
reorientation
and so really higher resolution is
available
um using these vertical rotors
especially when you're separating
particles that differ uh in differ in
terms of density on a pretty small scale
so things like partial and full capsids
for viral vectors for example
so
um looking in more detail about some of
these rotors and these are the most
common ones
I've already talked about each of these
a little bit but in terms of volume uh
the vti 50.1 is the newest rotor that
we've commercialized and it's got a
larger volume than any of the other ones
that I've talked about so far today
there's actually 12 by 39 mil capacity
for a total of nearly 500 mils
and if you look at how long it will take
you for an isopic separation in each of
each of these rotors that's laid out
there in the bottom of that table where
vti 50.1 is very clearly the fastest and
it also provides the best resolution
uh and so you can really form these
gradients faster get a higher resolution
and uh in addition to that these this
new rotor uh uses basically all the same
uh consumables tubes adapters everything
that that
um the rest of the rotors use
uh so now I can jump into some of these
case studies uh where we actually
provide some examples and specifics to
illustrate some of these things that
I've talked about so far
uh so this first one here uh was done
using that vti 50.1 rotor that I've
talked a lot about
um and what we start with there on the
top left is a uniform distribution of
our sample which in this case is
adenovirus serotype five
as well as cesium chloride and this was
done at a defined starting density of
1.35 grams per ml uh that should be
pretty close to the buoyant density of
adenovirus
we wrap this up as quickly as possible
uh in the xpn
um the Optima xpn centrifuge and we did
this exact same separation in a handful
of different rotors so starting at the
top we've got the swinging bucket in the
middle of the fixed angle and then at
the bottom the vti 50.1 or the vertical
rotor which we ran at two speeds
we then applied a maximum break to this
as I mentioned before and we measured
the position of each of these bands and
Quantified them using DLS
uh and then in those
um images that you can see there at the
bottom uh so the
um
fixed angle is the farthest on the left
there you see two distinct bands and
then farthest on the right is The
Swinging bucket rotor where you again
see two distinct bands what I really
want to point out here is that when we
did these separations in the vertical
rotor
we actually ended up seeing three
distinct bands for each of them uh and
so emergence of a third band is possible
uh again that's because of the higher
resolution that is is uh achievable
using these types of rotors so
um really a strong use case here for
vertical rotors when it comes to isopic
gradients
now jumping to the next one here
um this is really meant to not instead
of illustrating the resolution
illustrate the
um the time that it takes to get to
equilibrium with these rotors so same
type of layout as the previous slide but
instead there on the top left we're not
starting with a homogeneous
concentration so we did play a bit of a
trick here
where we're starting with layers so
we've got one layer at the bottom which
is a high density cesium chloride
solution
and then at the top is our sample
and we threw that in the vti 90 rotor uh
and did the exact same process as before
where we tried out a handful of
different situa um uh run speeds and and
times
then apply to maximum break and from
there it recovered the sample or
fractionated the tube and this was done
via manual fractionation
and if you look at that graph there at
the bottom you can see this is the
equilibrium scenario so this is what a
lot of customers have approached us
about you're running this thing for a
long time often overnight for 16 hours
and you can see the the gradient there
um in those gray dots so really you can
you can take a look at the range of that
gradient as well as the profile
but when we start to implement some
multi-speed runs so starting it at a
very high high speed and dropping it
down or
um adjusting those times as much as we
can
um you can see that in this case here
with the blue uh the blue dots there now
30 minutes at 90k and then an hour at
60k we get pretty close to where we were
with the 16 hour time point
now speed of a rotor is directly
correlated to the resolution That You
observe so higher speeds tend to favor
better sensitivity while lower speeds
favor better resolution
and so in this case
um you can see that there's quite a bit
of difference uh it's it's close but
it's not exactly where we want it to be
to get that exact uh exact same gradient
profile so we tried another run here
um there in red where we ran for 50
minutes at 90k and 30 minutes at 60k and
we see there that it's quite similar to
what we saw with the 16 hour run at 60k
so starting at a really high speed and
then dropping it down can allow you to
form these gradients faster and in this
particular case we were able to form
that continuous gradient in just 80
minutes using this vti 90 rotor
so now I'll jump into some of the key
takeaways from uh the presentation today
so starting here with
um
the instrument and some of the tubes
that are offered so our Flagship
instrument here is the Optima xpn which
is uh GMP supporting and we've got a ton
of tubes that are available for a
variety of different rotors these are
just five of the many options that we've
got at the smaller scale two mil tubes
which we've seen a lot of customers
Implement very successfully for uh sort
of process development and scaling up
and then on that larger scale once
you've developed a process up to the 39
mil tubes which is what our vti 50.1
rotor uses we've also got a fixed angle
rotor that uses 100 Mil tubes
and then in terms of tube format so
quick seal is probably the most common
thing that we've got especially for the
highest bio containment on the left
there is polypropylene which is really
um broadly compatible with a variety of
different materials
and then on the right side they're Ultra
clear and so you can see an example of
the visibility that's offered by these
types of tubes
uh we also sell Opti seal tubes
um and these are plug seal so much
simpler than what you get with the quick
seal not quite as high of Bio
containment but really ideal for fast
simple Ultra workflows especially at
that that r d type scale and environment
um we also offer open top tubes but
obviously those those won't work uh in a
vertical rotor
and in terms of the rotors themselves
these are the four that we've got
available today I've talked a little bit
about the vti 90 and and how quickly you
can form a continuous gradient in that
uh and this is uh using those smaller
scale tubes in the middle there with the
65.2 and 65.1 we've got
um a pretty good balance between speed
and uh number of samples or throughput
and then finally uh all the way on the
right there's the vti 50.1 which is the
um largest capacity vertical rotor on
the market
so to wrap things up here
um I'll go through some of these
conclusions so
density gradients are are typically
chosen when you've got a relatively
difficult separation
um in other words there's a very subtle
difference between what you're trying to
separate out and what you're trying to
purify and also because of high Purity
and high yield so some examples of this
are are viral vectors plasmids
extracellular vesicles
and then within that dguc realm rate
zonal runs are which are a separation
based on size and mass or sedimentation
coefficient
are best suited for swinging bucket
rotors
and then isopic or equilibrium zonal
runs
um in other words a separation basis on
the basis of buoyant density
is done using vertical rotors
so to go over some of the benefits of
these vertical rotors
um first of all it's high Purity I
talked about the shallow density
gradients that are formed because
there's a pretty minimal shift in um
centrifugal force between the inner and
outer radius of the tubes so those offer
the highest resolution
in terms of yield these particles really
are getting compressed into these these
very discrete type bands and so very
often it's very easy easy to visualize
these and precisely extract them from
the tube
run times are shorter in these vertical
rotors as well because you can achieve
equilibrium faster
in terms of capacity I already mentioned
the 50.1 is the highest capacity
vertical rotor on the market and then
finally with dguc as a whole
these techniques are serotype
independent right all three of the ones
I've discussed today so each tube in a
single run could be a different sample
or a different stereotype and the
highest uh
different sample type rotor that we've
got is for 16. so really great in an r d
environment as well as in larger scale
workflows as well
and then finally
I've also mentioned how these cesium
chloride density gradients can be
reduced in 80 minutes using the smaller
scale vti 90 rotor it's really fantastic
for sort of building out your process at
that smaller scale and not using quite
as much sample to do it and then scaling
up from there is is quite simple as the
process Remains the Same the only thing
that has to be accounted for is slightly
different speeds and dimensions in the
tubes that you're using
so with that I'd like to
um thank thank everyone for your
attention today and uh just briefly
mention that we've got a lot of
additional content that's available on
vertical rotors as well as density
gradient Ultra centrifugation at large
um so I'm just sharing some of these
here but if you go to our website we can
act you can access a lot more of those
thank you
thank you Sean for your informative
presentation if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click the ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what purification scale is possible with
density gradients how much time do the
vertical rotors save
uh thank you that's a that's a great
question and and one that we get quite
often uh really it comes down to what
you're trying to purify and and what
your workflow looks like
um I tend to always default to viral
vectors that's what I hear most people
working on these days
um and so we've got these vertical
rotors implemented in r d workflows and
I've already talked a little bit about
um how the serotype independent nature
of these techniques is an advantage
there
um you know every every hole in the
rotor can be something different but
then to your question all the way to PD
and Manufacturing
um 50 liter bioreactors are commonly
purified in a single run but we've also
got a lot of customers that have really
strong concentration steps prior to
centrifugation so typically this is done
using tff or tangential flow filtration
um or on on the smaller scale if you've
got a need for that centrifugal spin
filters work quite well and so with that
concentration step we've got customers
that are able to do 200 liter reactors
in a single rotor especially with the
the higher volume one
um and then the the second part of that
question is as far as Time Savings goes
again it's somewhat case uh Case by case
um but as I mentioned before many of our
customers are running these dguc
experiments overnight so 16 to 22 hours
for cesium chloride tends to be pretty
common
um but what that tells me is that
there's a lot of room for optimization
and Time Savings in many of these cases
I shared the example for
uh the the case study there with with
CBM uh where we saw really strong
purification and separation between
those species in in uh six to nine hours
and then on the smaller scale
um that vti 90 rotor can form a gradient
and a linear gradient in 80 minutes so
there really is a big potential for Time
Savings in most cases by switching to
these rotors but speed has to be
accounted for as well
great thank you uh my next question do
you have any tips for recovering sample
after dguc
yeah this tends to be one of the pain
points in the process I don't think
anyone really loves the way things are
currently done
um one thing that's often overlooked I
think is uh
the lab setup and the layout that that
can be really crucial for this uh so
what I mean by that is setting the
centrifuges close as possible to the
hood or or where you're actually doing
the work in terms of extracting your
sample from it you want to make sure
you're not moving these tubes around too
much after the gradient has been formed
um two common methods for this are as I
mentioned extraction and fractionation
uh so extraction is just using a syringe
and a needle to actually pluck out the
the band that you see there
um and one of the things that helps a
lot with that is for uh is putting a
light underneath the tube so there's
some flat kind of lights that we use I
think I purchased them on Amazon for our
lab and those can slide right underneath
pretty well and illuminate things and
allow you to see it see the band quite a
bit better
uh and then in terms of
um material so
we offer polypropylene and Ultra clear
polypropylene is is very compatible with
with most solutions and Ultra clear
tends to provide higher visibility but I
think in terms of piercing the tube
itself uh polypropylene is is a little
bit easier to do
and then also I I briefly mentioned this
but fractionation using a chromatography
system is becoming more and more popular
as kind of an automated approach to to
actually doing this
thank you
um do you have any recommendations or
suggestions for separating precursor
phage
um capsids that have different amounts
of protein that can be an ex
um unexpanded semi-expanded and fully
expanded and no DNA using the vertical
rotors
that's an interesting application
um it sounds like there would be some
discrete differences in density between
each of those different species so I
would assume a density gradient probably
linear given that there's a lot of
different subpopulations there would
work quite well for this and obviously
as I said the vertical rotors tend to be
the best for these types of
purifications in terms of
recommendations I'd have to try to
understand your workflow a bit better
but perhaps that's something we can chat
about offline I can I can follow up with
you
great
um in the first case study why is there
only one lower band visible with the
50.2
uh yeah so that's the the 50.2 is the
fixed angle rotor that we used in there
um and the thought there is that it just
simply hasn't reached equilibrium yet
um you know the sample was exactly the
same going into all of those tubes and
rotors uh so really I think it's just
that the material that makes up that
band has not been compressed into a
tight band yet and that's
probably due to the longer path length
um that those fixed angled rotors have
compared to the vertical
great thank you our next question what
kind of throughput is possible using
dguc
this is another common question we get
to
um a bit of a tricky one but I'm
assuming you're meaning a number of
samples here so of the vertical rotor
options that we have uh the vti 65.2 is
the most samples so you can run up to 16
samples at once
um
and it won't be able to purify quite as
fast as the vti 90 and in terms of
thinking in terms of throughput here but
I would assume within a few hours you'd
be good to go if you have an optimized
optimized method using that rotor
great
um our next question is gradient
reorientation a problem in vertical
rotors wouldn't swinging bucket be
better
um not really the the tubes that we have
are are designed to allow for that
smooth reorientation and going back
again to that that first case study it
might have been a bit hard to see in the
images
but that was Illustrated kind of in
there where we've got
um visible bands looking exactly the
same in both of the rotors the swing
bucket or vertical so reorientation
doesn't seem to really play a role there
in terms of what the output actually is
uh and then also the max break thing too
I do want to point that out one more
time because it's often surprising when
I talk to people about this but that
study was done using applying maximum
break so no coasting at all
um uh for everything so really a I don't
think there's a need to have that extra
long step there at the end in most cases
our next question my ultra doesn't have
the option of doing a multi-speed
protocol why
so for the Beckman
um floor models we've got two that we
that we sell and those are the XE and
the xpn
um the XE tends to be a little bit
cheaper but the xpn has that multi-speed
option along with some other improved
software features including kind of a
smart software as well as more the GMP
supporting so it's probably that you
have the the XE rather than the xpn
and it looks like we have one more
question here can you elaborate on
breaking and coasting to stop the run
yeah um
coasting has always been the traditional
approach I think for this
um and depending on the speed that
you're running at and the type of rotor
that you use uh it can take over an hour
sometimes uh and on our instruments
um I think there's either nine or ten
different options to choose from in
terms of so on a zero to nine scale zero
might be coasting completely no break
applied whatsoever so coming down from
say 90 000 RPM can take a really long
time there and then on the the other end
of that scale a nine being maximum break
which usually stops in just a few
minutes
um however we've we've not seen any real
data illustrating you know why that
coasting step is needed um nor have we
in our own hands seen any quantifiable
difference between coasting or or
applying Max break
uh so my recommendation to people is is
to to go with a maximum Break
um and you know that that
slide that I shared for the CVM study
which is kind of an application brief
that we have available online
um that was all match break too so
um yeah that's my thoughts on it
great thank you so much that looks like
it brings us to the end of our q a
portion
um do you have any Final Cut
um comments for our audience
I'll just say that
um if anyone wants to follow up with me
um I can definitely get your information
from Lab routes and and have a chat
we're always looking for opportunities
to
um you know learn more about customer
workflows and and provide some of this
guidance in terms of how to optimize
implement or optimize dguc and then also
we're we're always open for
collaborations as well and a lot of the
stuff that I presented today was was
done using collaborations so thank you
yeah thank you again Sean for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor Beckman Coulter for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we'd go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
they're interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye